du sport dans le s p de suite de ce 28
février du rugby plus précisément avec
olivier nero 9 bonsoir vous êtes seul le
président du club de versailles et puis
jean claude thélier bonsoir à vous vice
président du comité départemental de
rugby la ligue de rugby et ses journées
des ambassadeurs qui se sont installés
dans les yvelines à versailles hier et
aujourd'hui les ambassadeurs ce sont
deux anciens professionnels des arbitres
des spécialistes de l'ovalie qui
viennent mieux faire connaître le rugby
et ses valeurs dans les régions et les
villes de france qui n'accueille pas de
club professionnel
jean-claude seguer justement le rugby
dans le département et puis à versailles
aussi avait besoin de ce coup de pouce
de ce dispositif pour valoriser le ring
mais de toute façon partir du moment où
on fait quelque chose c'est
indispensable
il est évident que le comité
départemental en bas la ligue mais le
comité départemental de rugby est très
contents d'accueillir bien sûr dans son
appartement versailles et à la capitale
du département
donc en plus de l'île de france qui
représente beaucoup de monde nous sommes
le premier comité départemental avec
plus de cette pile dix ans y est donc le
rugby déjà se porte bien dans le
département rugby et aux aidants les
pratiquement tout premier de france au
point de vue département voire même est
puni important en licencier que
certaines régions c'est vous dire que
nous sommes très fiers et nous sommes
surtout fiers de nos jeunes
lorsque nous avons beaucoup de jeunes
nous travaillons avec des produits de la
ferme non pas chercher ailleurs
évidemment nous ne sommes pas au plus
haut niveau mais beaucoup de choses font
que c'est très difficile et très serré
lille justement pourquoi n'y a pas de
club professionnel pourquoi le club de
versailles par exemple n'est pas un club
professionnel cela on va passer a valu
mon ami obili équivalent déclaré mais je
pense que tout le monde peut l'expliquer
bah écoutez le club de versailles
d'abord 5e extrêmement anciens puisque
il est considéré comme un ancêtre par la
fédération son début comme on remonte à
1893 donc on est là verser versailles
largement largement centenaire alors
aujourd'hui bon je veux dire le club
s'est monté bien sûr à partir des lycées
et principalement à versailles aussi une
population c'est logique importante qui
ait les milieux scouts et louveteaux
traditionnels qui sont venus rejoindre
le club de rugby donc finalement à
partir de ça on a essayé de bâtir un
club qui a aujourd'hui atteint dépasse
même les 500 licenciés ce seulement je
veux dire pour pouvoir monter
interprofessionnelle il faut avoir des
finances et un budget qui n'est
absolument pas au niveau de ce big o
dont on peut disposer aujourd'hui mais
c'est un regret que vous avez ou la
situation alors qu'elles sont licenciés
dont plus de la moitié d'enfants s'avoue
satisfait on va écouter aujourd'hui et
258 250 enfants à l'école de rugby pour
nous c'est formidable ça veut dire qu'on
a mis on ne le club de versailles est
avant tout un club formateur bon son
niveau aujourd'hui c'est au décès c'est
que l'équipe senior et au niveau de la
chapelle france de fédérale 3 on
pourrait envisager à terme de d'aboutir
au niveau supérieur de la fédérale 2
mais après on est pris dans un haut
niveau de compétences à la fois
rugbystique et en même temps financière
donc imaginer versa et en professionnel
c'est irréalisable et vous formez vous
l'avez dit c'est un club formateur celui
et de versailles on va écouter à l'un
des ambassadeurs justement de cette
année qui est passé par votre club
c'est thomas lombard quatre fois
champion de france avec le stade
français finaliste de la coupe d'europe
également en 2001 il est passé par le
rcv le rc versailles on les écoute au
micro d'anthony rech lors justement de
ces différentes journées des
ambassadeurs qui ont débuté hier à
versailles
je suis à présent à côté de thomas
lombard ancien trois-quart centre
international du quinze de france on est
devant un atelier là qui va avoir lieu
tout de suite de rock je vous entends
des de leur donner des consignes
quel est l'état d'esprit pour vous
aujourd'hui avec ces jeunes c'est de l'
enthousiasme tout simplement qu'il faut
leur communiqué je crois que sont encore
au stade où on se se pose pas de
question de savoir pourquoi comment
la donnée fondamentale c'est le plaisir
donc c
essayer de leur faire comprendre qu'avec
quelques petits points de deux
règlements ou technique on peut on peut
prendre encore un petit peu plus plaisir
après ils sont ils sont encore tout
petit et l'idée ce n'est pas de les
enfermer dans des carcans n'est pas on
n'est pas si on s'adresse pas à des
professionnels on s'adresse à des gamins
donc il faut leur donner envie justement
de de devenir peut-être des
professionnels et ça passe par ce par
cette idée bah voilà de prendre du
plaisir d'apprécier le moment est de
s'amuser lors de cette journée des
ambassadeurs de rugby c'est un peu un
retour aux sources pour vous vos
premiers entraînements en centre de
formation par exemple
à mon époque et pas de centre de
formation et donc que c'était mais mes
premiers débuts à l'école de rugby aux
chaînés puis ici à versailles après ça
c'est une aventure c'était s'était
prolongé donc ouais c'est un peu faire
une des particularités du rugby du sport
et puis dans un titre plus générale de
la vie ce qu'on retrouve toujours des
jambes donc ça faisait
moment que je n'étais pas revenu ici 25
ans pour être précis mêlée mais des gens
sont encore là quoi donc
l'idée aussi du du retour et de de
rendre un peu de ce qu'on a de ce qu'on
a reçu quoi c'est c'est une usine d une
des vertus à laquelle on est éduqué dans
des écoles de rugby sert de camp rugby
c'est bien et dans la vie d'un point
final c'est bien de prendre mais c'est
aussi bien de donner
donc voilà je suis là pour rendre un
petit peu modestement à tous ces gens
qui alors là par contre ont pris sur
leur temps de famille sur le plan de
travail pour pour encadrer des petits
gamins qui je l'espère demain ce seront
des grands jours de rugby justement
quand vous étiez jeunes dans ce club là
donc à versailles l'importance des
bénévoles et est vraiment prédominante
gens me dire bah c'est là c'est la clé
de voûte c'est les gens qui sans qu'ils
plutôt le le rugby au niveau amateur
n'existerait pas et est encore plus et
encore plus fort à eux niveau
international puisque tous les joueurs
sont passés par des centres comme celui
de versailles des petites
infrastructures des petites écoles de
rugby parce que c'est pas des clubs qui
sont ni très huppé d'un point de vue
d'un point de vue financier ni même
sportivement mais qui ont parfois et
c'est souvent le cas d'ailleurs les
bénévoles les plus assidus c'est pas
dans les
c'est pas dans les grands grands clubs
qu'on trouve les meilleurs éducateurs
dieu merci ne les vrais passionnés on
les trouve souvent à la à la base de la
pyramide et donc il faut il faut aussi
leur rendre hommage à ces gens là
presque son 100e le rugby n'existerait
pas ou en tout cas ce serait se seraient
perdus sur d'autres sur d'autres chemins
donc c'est aussi une des raisons pour
lesquelles on est on est là vous parliez
de transmission cette journée c'est
l'occasion aussi de parler des valeurs
du rugby les transmettre à ses enfants
là c'est ça aussi qui fait que vous
aimer ce sport autant
oui bah
inévitablement quand on prononce
construit quand on est un jeune garçon
qu'on arrive dans ce dans ce milieu et
qu'on s'y trouve à l'aise c'est
forcément qu'on se retrouve dans les
danses qu'on nous apprend c'est à dire
le respect la solidarité
l'altruisme voilà l'engagement le combat
collectif c'est qui c'est quand même des
vertus qui sont propres aux sports et au
rugby en particulier puisque le régler
quand même le seul sport de combat
collectif qui existent et les sports de
contact il ya des sports où parfois on
se rentre dedans mais des sports de
combat collectif il n'y en a pas d'autre
selon donc vous jouez trois quarts aile
pilier deuxième ligne c'est pas les
mêmes responsabilités c'est pas le même
travail qu'en vous demande mais le plus
de finales il est même quoi c'est le
fonctionnement le fonctionnement de
l'équipe et c'est faire abstraction de
pas mal de choses donc il ya des liens
ya des liens qui se créent
merci beaucoup thomas et bonne ateliers
de rock merci thomas lombard l'un des
ambassadeurs présents à versailles est
un beau peut-être du président du club
sur le parcours de thomas lombard qui
restent encore attaché au club de
versailles écoutez moi thomas lombard
comme je suis là dedans ce club depuis
très très longtemps d'ailleurs comme le
prix dans ces gains j'ai connu ou à
l'école de rugby j'ai connu en cadet et
d'ailleurs paradoxalement il a quitté le
club en cadet 2e année par un match
contre le racing club de france en 16e
de finale ce plat de france cette année
là le racing club de france est devenu
champion de france
il a rejoint le racing club de france
avec lequel il a été champion de france
crabos avec un autre versailles et
l'année d'après arnaud barey qu'est le
gérant du pavot paris à versailles
donc tout ça c'est une grande histoire
de famille est un éternel recommencement
et avec des succès et beaucoup de
convivialité
thomas lombard donc ensuite c'est on le
disait tout à l'heure quatre titres de
champion de france un haut niveau au
niveau au plus haut niveau justement
alors on parle souvent des valeurs du
rugby aussi c'est aussi l'objectif de
ces différentes journées des
ambassadeurs deux jours qui se sont
déroulés à versailles aura d'autres
rendez vous à travers la france dans les
prochains mois ces valeurs du rugby
c'est quoi aujourd'hui les valeurs de
rubis sait déjà que on essaye de bien se
tenir
sur le terrain on l'entend pas vociférer
et le fair play est la règle le ciment
de notre
oui et c'est ce que développe le
président perrier avec son équipe dont
je m'honore de faire partie on commence
à on et jade et les tout petits puisque
nous avons un tournoi le seul d'ailleurs
en france qui réunit 300 au minimum 300
enfants me dis enfin niveau maternelle
et cours préparatoire
c'est à dire 5 7 ans et déjà non
seulement ce travail est fait la
citoyenneté
le combat ne pas avoir peur et avoir les
parents qui se tiennent bien
c'est notre but c'est le but avec bien
sûr la formation et le comité
départemental bien sûr ne fait pas que
du rugby
il s'ouvre aussi il participe aux
olympiens du vivre ensemble qu'est ce
que les olympiens différence ans et les
handicapés moteurs les handicapés
mentaux et les valides
le rugby est là on dépasse le cadre où
on passe il véritablement pour les
foulées olympique séparaient donc le
rugby c'est l'école de la vie en ville
c'est quelque chose qui ait pris
beaucoup qui est galvaudé même mais je
pense que le comité départemental et
bien sûr parce que c'est aussi mon club
le racing club le rugby club dé
versailles et sur le droit fil tout ce
que nous aimons est à la pointe de ce
que vous voulez développer dans le
département voilà c'est le message est
passé pour les autres clubs qui
pourraient écouter cette cette séquence
ce plateau du 7 8 au cours duquel nous
parlons donc de ces journées des
ambassadeurs opération nationale qui
permet justement de faire venir des
vedettes du rugby dans différentes
communes pour valoriser le rugby on a vu
les enfants on image on en a parlé aussi
mais ces journées ne s'adresse pas qu'à
eux
il ya eu aussi des rencontres par
exemple avec le cfa tecomah voilà des
étudiants des plus grands déjà qu'ils
ont rencontré aussi ses ambassadeurs du
rugby c'est ça c'est journée du rugby
ces journées des ambassadeurs faut que
ça touche tout le monde oui les salariés
des jeunes et oui aussi sa touche aussi
à ce thème général quel partenaire en
deuil national professionnel de rugby et
qui a stimulé ces équipes qui les a fait
venir au club house du terrain de sport
centaine organisé un séminaire et a mis
toutes ses équipes sur le terrain pour
un stage
motivation physique les salariés de la
société générale sont allés se frotter
aux idées mènent sur le terrain est
absolument est-ce qu'ils vont venir
jouer bien sûr oui bien sûr il ya ceux
du général est là parce que elle met en
parallèle les valeurs du rugby et les
valeurs de l'entreprise quelle qu'elles
qu'elles communiquent nord possède ses
salariés donc voila et il le fait qu'on
ait une relation privilégiée que c'est
général de versailles a permis donc la
possibilité d'organiser ces journées
ambassadeur sur notre stade de
porchefontaine et on doit les remercier
autant que la ligue nationale parce que
le rugby autres ambassadeurs jérôme
cazalbou lui aussi a été plusieurs fois
champion de france 1 ces petites re de
champion de france il a évolué au stade
toulousain et il nous parle aussi des
valeurs de ce sport toujours au micro
d'anthony rech
je suis à présent à côté de jérôme
cazalbou ancien demi de mêlée
international du quinze de france
bonjour jérôme bonjour alors c'était
important pour vous aussi d'être là
aujourd'hui
lors de cette journée des ambassadeurs
de rugby et surtout d'échanger avec les
jeunes oui c'est extrêmement important
parce qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde voit
un petit peu la vitrine le rugby
professionnel que ce soit à travers le
top 14 et la pro d2 et l'équipe de
france mais avant tout il ya la base il
ya le socle toutes les personnes qui
oeuvrent toutes les semaines pour former
les gamins de demain et puis tout
simplement aussi parce que les joueurs
qui aujourd'hui évolue en ahl caisses de
france pour la plupart ou à la quasi
majorité ils ont été formés dans des
petits clubs qui évoluent
dans les séries régionales qui évolue
dans le milieu de la fédérale et il est
normal
un petit peu parce que nous aussi on en
est issu j'ai commencé dans un club qui
évolue encore et toujours en 2e série
régionales en haute garonne
il est normal ça fait partie des 30
unités tradition du rugby et des valeurs
du rugby qu'après avoir reçu mais c'est
à notre tour de données et aujourd'hui
on en est on donne toujours avec plaisir
c'est surtout ça qui est important
et vous donnez aussi transmettez les
valeurs essentielles con qu'on aime
souvent autour de ce sport c'est ça oui
je crois que de façon aussi ce sport vit
et survit et se différencient parfois
d'autres sports parce que justement on
arrive à conserver ses valeurs et cette
opération menée par la ligue nationale
de rugby la société générale elle nous
permet effectivement de continuer à
porter ces valeurs et de montrer aux
plus jeunes que sevellec ses valeurs
elle existe toujours au plus haut niveau
ça veut dire que si un jour ils ont la
chance d'évoluer au plus haut niveau ils
seront aussi les garants de ses valeurs
ses valeurs justement quand vous parlez
aux enfants là depuis tout à l'heure
c'est respect c'est tolérance c'est ça
c'est ce qui compte
il ya ça il ya surtout aussi prise de
plaisir ça c'est important
mais yahia le respect le respect de
l'éducateur le respect de la règle
l'esprit d'équipé jouer avec les autres
ne pas jouer individuellement
et puis et puis on leur a parlé un petit
peu avant leur disant que le rugby
c'était bien que le rugby est
professionnel ça pouvait très bien mais
on a aussi un message à leur faire
passer c'est qu'il faut aussi qu'il aime
bien bossé à l'école parce que certains
réussiront et d'autres ne réussiront pas
et donc voilà
quand on a la tête bien pleine on est
aussi un bon joueur et l'homme ne va pas
sans l'autre
ces journées c'est aussi de l'occasion
comme vous le soulignez de dire qu' il
n'y a pas de rugby sans école elle aussi
le rugby est indissociable du monde
professionnel derrière
oui il n'ya pas de rugby sans école
parce qu'on ne peut pas devenir un grand
joueur ça va être passée normalement par
une école de rugby avoir écouté ses
éducateurs avoir été bien formé et puis
aujourd'hui si un rugby de haut niveau
c'est grâce surtout à ce qu'il y ait des
clubs qui sont un niveau plus bas mais
qui prennent du temps pour former les
enfants
et puis pour de leur donner les bons
réflexes et justement les bonnes valeurs
et pour vous personnellement c'est un
peu un retour aux sources vous disiez
que votre club d'origine et est encore
dans une division un peu inférieur c'est
ça c'est le retour aux sources que vous
appréciez on apprécie beaucoup de choses
tu ressens le rugby c'est aussi un
moment de partage c'est de la
convivialité et là sur cette opération
avec les gens
les ambassadeurs que ce soit
effectivement aujourd'hui sur les
terrains comme demain lorsqu on
échangera avec des chefs d'entreprise
avec des étudiants à la mairie de
versailles
hulu avec les collaborateurs société
générale eh bien on essaye de faire
passer cette passion de faire passer
cette envie de continuer à porter des
messages
et puis surtout à échanger à échanger et
de montrer que même si aujourd'hui le
rugby est devenu professionnel
eh bien il ya toujours une proximité
entre les acteurs les supporters et puis
le public qui s'intéresse de plus en
plus merci beaucoup et on avait plaisir
de ses ambassadeurs justement il a
évoqué le haut niveau la formation au
plus haut niveau est ce que ces journées
des ambassadeurs vont aussi permettre de
déceler de nouveaux talents alors
forcément vous voyez un petit sourire se
dessine et je pense aux difficultés du
15 actuelle il ya quelques difficultés
dans le monde professionnel
est-ce que là c'est journée c'est aussi
pour ça c'est aussi pour chercher déjà
tout pourquoi pas mais je pense comme le
disait le président olivier notre
travail si surtout de former et le
comité départemental justement fait
énormément pour la formation envoie ses
missi dominici pour que le rugby
progresse si l'on peut arriver
professionnels et haut niveau c'est un
plus mais comme le disait tout à l'heure
olivier le tout c'est de se sentir bien
d'être en bonne forme de représenter une
éthique très importante mais le reste
nous l'attendons si ça nous est donné
tant mieux un mot tout de même juste
pour conclure un pronostic cette
cuillère en bois pour le tournoi des six
nations pour l'équipe de france
on rappelle s'est décerné à l'équipe qui
perd tous ses matches du tournoi des six
nations la france qui est plutôt bien
parti malheureusement pour la décrocher
la dernière fois pour la france étant 57
le rugby ce n'est pas la guerre nous ne
leur ont pas c'est sûr mais même si nous
l'avions c'est pas un deuil national
faudra s'en remettre a tout de même
parce que depuis cinquante-sept je suis
pas sûr que ça fasse plaisir à philippe
saint-andré même pronostic c'est
impossible qu'on ait la cuillère de bois
le message est clair le message est
passé auprès des joueurs professionnels
merci messieurs merci à tous les deux
prochaines étapes des ambassadeurs du
rugby dont nous parlions ce sera à niort
1 13 et 14 mars l'opération se déplacent
partout en france
elle sous l'égide de la société générale
qui en est le partenaire on l'a
mentionné ce soir à suivre la chronique
l'économie justement avec claire combi
et puis le boom du e-commerce mais déjà
rencontre avec deux femmes eliette
daudet sophie totti lutte et elles sont
toutes les deux restauratrices elle
travaille sur un salon du 19e siècle au
musée national de port des champs à
magny les hameaux port royal des champs
avec valérie horrible elles se sont
rencontrés voilà vingt ans dans un
atelier de peinture de techniques
anciennes
le chantier de restauration d'un salon
du 19e siècle du musée national de port
royal des champs à magny les hameaux
l occasion pour sophie eliette d'allier
leurs talents pour la première fois et
de mêlée restauration et approches d'un
chantier traditionnels ce sont des
chantiers qui à l'époque était balisé
par des peintre en décor donc jelal
approche pratique du deux chantiers
finalement donc là la restauration est
un petit peu particulière dans la mesure
où
on a eu un côté restauration toute une
partie restauration qui est quand même
du concert depuis la moitié du salon et
une partie restitution puisque l'on a
découvert que ce salon avait été
restitué déjà au 19e siècle
le chantier a débuté par la
réintégration pictural en octobre 2012
mais les premières peintures ont été
découvertes et nettoyer il y a plus de
trois ans tels deux archéologues sophie
et eliette ont découvert leurs
différentes couches successives en
remontant dans le temps jusqu'à
découvrir la teinte originale du xviiie
siècle patiner presque bronze à cause de
l'oxydation et divers traitements aux
huiles et occire redécouvrir la couleur
originale ne fut pas chose aisée les
peintures de dessus de porte ont
largement renseigner nous deux
expertises alors je suis empreint d'un
coup une troisième couche leur la couche
de peinture verte
frash à la colle de peau il a été
réalisé avec les pigments de la colle de
peau pour réintégrer c'est à dire pour
eux re donner l'illusion de de
l'ensemble alors bien longtemps
le déborde pas sur la peinture originale
que l'on a conservé les tableaux
entièrement re marouflé sur un nid
d'abeille conservent leur plastique de
protection pour éviter les coulures le
salon est l'un des derniers des corrs
anciens du musée qui n'avait pas encore
été restauré l'opération devrait
s'achever au printemps le salon
accueillera les premiers visiteurs pour
la nuit des musées en mai 2013
d'ici là seule plume peut en profiter